Законопроект про Антикорупційний суд,
який у першому читанні схвалила Верховна Рада,
містить усі рекомендації Венеціанської комісії.
Принаймні, так стверджує президент України
Петро Порошенко.
Чіткі рекомендації щодо того, яким має бути
Антикорупційний суд, Венеціанська комісія надала
ще торік у жовтні. Проте через два місяці, 22 грудня,
президент вніс свій законопроект щодо суду,
який не відповідав ключовим вимогам
"Венеціанки". Тоді про це заявила низка українських
антикорупційних організацій. Пізніше до критики
президентського варіанту закону долучилися і
ключові міжнародні партнери України -
МВФ, Світовий банк і ЄС.
По-перше, головна претензія до механізму відбору
суддів. Венеціанська комісія радила, щоб роль
Громадської ради міжнародних експертів
під час відбору кандидатів у судді була
вирішальною, а не просто дорадчою.
Щоб Громадська рада мала право блокувати
недоброчесних суддів. У президентському варіанті
цього не враховано, і контроль над процесом
залишається за Вищою кваліфікаційною комісією,
яка двома третинами голосів може просто
проігнорувати думку Громадської ради.
По-друге, надмірні вимоги до кандидатів
у антикорупційні судді. "Венеціанка" радила
залучити найширше коло суддів, адвокатів та
науковців до конкурсу. Президентський же варіант,
навпаки, значно ускладнює конкуренцію,
вимагаючи від кандидатів одночасно мати
як великий досвід роботи в Україні, так і чималу
практику в міжнародних антикорупційних
організаціях чи міжнародних судових установах.
По-третє, юрисдикція Антикорупційного суду.
Венеціанська комісія чітко вказувала, що
юрисдикція майбутнього суду має відповідати
підслідності НАБУ і Спеціальної антикорупційної
прокуратури. Однак президентський варіант
поширюється і на не пов'язані з корупцією справи,
зокрема на торгівлю наркотиками та зброєю, в яких
беруть участь посадові особи. Це може завалити
Антикорупційний суд купою справ і заблокувати
його роботу.
Президент Порошенко не врахував
ключові рекомендації Венеціанської комісії
у своєму законопроекті про Антикорупційний суд.
Зокрема щодо процедури відбору суддів, вимог
до кандидатів і юрисдикції суду, а також
положень закону, які гальмують створення суду.
Щоправда, президент пообіцяв, що між першим
і другим читанням депутати можуть внести зміни
у законопроект і врахувати рекомендації
"Венеціанки". Утім, напрошується питання:
чому цього не зробили досі?